All the meta data in the world doesn't
help if we never actually build
the Widget Provider.
This is the class that has the logic for
building the view for the widget, and
passing it on to the launcher app.
It does that through
the use of a special class,
Remote Views, because these views
need to go across applications, and
break their traditional
sandbox provided for each app.
Only a subset of the normal
views are supported for widgets.
No custom views are allowed.
Thankfully, all of the common views
you use in normal Android view layouts
are available to your widgets.
In fact,
you'll build your widget layouts in XML,
just the same as you would for
any other layout in your app.
One caveat with widgets
has to do with margins.
Prior to Android 4, Ice Cream Sandwich,
widgets needed to beride their own
margins so that widgets wouldn't
appear huge next to the app icons
already on the home screen.
On Android 4.0 and higher, however, the
margins are automatically applied for
you, and your background
should fill the entire space.
To make our widget backward compatible,
we can wrap our widget
in a FrameLayout that includes
the correct padding for each API level.
So what does this mythical AppWidget
Provider class we've talked about
actually do?
The core of it is in
the onUpdate method.
This is where we surprisingly
update our widgets.
We've got a list of appWidgetIds,
unique identifiers for
each widget the user has created.
And it's your job,
should you choose to accept it,
to update all of those widgets.
Thankfully, that's pretty easy for
static widgets.
Create your RemoteViews object, and
pass it on to the AppWidgetManager
you're given.
But even that's not very useful.
The setOnClickPendingIntent method
allows you to control what happens
when you tap on your widget.
The only final piece we need
to get our widget up and
running is an entry in
the Android Manifest.
It ties our AppWidget provider
To our AppWidget provider info.
You'll note,
the AppWidget update action here.
That's what tells Android that
this is a widget provider.
And our meta data attribute, so it tells
Android where to find the meta data it
needs to display the widget in
the widget selection screen..
With all those pieces in place,
we should be able to get a basic
widget showing up on the home screen.